members of the nevada national guard are  headed to washington d.c tomorrow  to lend a hand during president-elect  joe biden's inauguration  washington d.c has become a fortress  following that assault on the capitol  you have some of the best of the best  nevada has to offer they're prepared for  every mission that  is given out by the national capital  region and so to be able to go to the  inauguration  and to make a contribution based off of  what we may do from  traffic control or entry points etc  these are the people that we want there  in fact  national guards from nearly all 50  states are going to be there  additionally local and federal officials  in the capitol expect around 20  thousand federal national guard members  to be involved as well